>> Raymond: WELCOME BACK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GEARING UP
FOR A FIGHT WITH CONGRESS OVER
FUNDING FOR A NEW BORDER WALL.
WITH THE MIGRANT CARAVAN
KNOCKING ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER,
THE PRESIDENT BELIEVES WE NEED
IT NOW AND COULDN'T BE MORE
URGENT.
>> COULD HAPPEN.
OVER BORDER SECURITY.
THE WALL IS JUST A PART OF
BORDER SECURITY.
VERY IMPORTANT.
PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
PART.
COULD HAVE BE A SHUT DOWN?
CERTAINLY COULD.
IT WILL BE ABOUT BORDER
SECURITY, OF WHICH THE WALL IS A
PART.
>> Raymond: IS A SHUT DOWN
LOOMING?
HERE TO REACT, DAVID BERSTEIN,
CEO OF RUN FOR AMERICA AND
AUDRIA DECKER, A CONSERVATIVE
COMMENTATOR.
AUDRIA, DOES THE PRESIDENT HAVE
ENOUGH SUPPORT TO GET THE BORDER
WALL FUND SOMETHING HE COULDN'T
GET IT LAST TIME.
>> HIS JOB IS TO ENFORCE THE
LAWS ON THE BOOKS.
THE FACT IS, WE HAVE BORDERS IN
OUR NATION.
PEOPLE CAN'T JUST DECIDE THEY'RE
GOING TO CROSS OVER WITHOUT
PERMISSION.
WE NEED A SYSTEM IN AMERICA THAT
IS FAIR TO THE PEOPLE WAITING IN
LINE AND TO ALSO THE PEOPLE THAT
WANT TO COME OVER.
ABSOLUTELY.
HE NEEDS TO DO WHATEVER HE NEEDS
TO TO SECURE THE BORDER.
>> Raymond: THE REPUBLICANS
HAVEN'T JOINED HIM.
THERE'S A UNITY IN THE CAUCUS,
THIS IS CONGRESSMAN PETE KING
TALKING ABOUT THIS GOVERNMENT
SHUT DOWN AND WHO IT MIGHT HURT.
WATCH.
>> I STRONGLY SUPPORT FUNDING
THE BORDER WALL, BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE WE SHOULD SHUT THE
GOVERNMENT DOWN.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO KEEP
THE GOVERNMENT GOING.
POLITICALLY, THIS WOULD PLAY
INTO THE HANDS OF THE
GOVERNMENT.
THE WALL WON'T BE BUILT AND
WON'T BE FUNDED AND WE'LL BE
BLAMED FOR IT.
>> Raymond: WILL IT HURT
REPUBLICANS?
>> YES.
PEOPLE VOTED FOR CHANGE.
PEOPLE VOTED FOR ACTION.
SHUTTING DOWN THE GOVERNMENT IS
NOT WHAT PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR.
BEING PRESIDENT, THERE'S A
RESPONSIBILITY TO GET IT DONE.
>> Raymond: DIDN'T HURT WHEN
NEWT GINGRICH DID IT.
THEY TURNED OUT WELL.
WHAT IS PAUL RYAN?
WHERE NOT IN HIS FINAL ACT AS
SPEAKER AND WITH THIS CAUCUS,
MANY PEOPLE ARE LEAVING, WHY NOT
SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT IN THIS
PROMISE HE MADE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT GOT MANY ELECTED THE
LAST TIME?
>> THE REPUBLICANS SHOULD BE
FIGHTING FOR THIS AND THEY'RE
NOT.
PART OF THE REASON WHY TRUMP
BROUGHT THIS UP, HE'S A GREAT
NEGOTIATOR.
WE KNOW THAT HE HAS TO PUSH THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY TO TAKE ACTION
ON IMPORTANT ISSUES.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP RAN ON AND GOT ELECTED ON.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT TO SEE
THIS HAPPEN.
>> Raymond: IT'S ALMOST
CHRISTMAS TIME.
LET'S RUN THROUGH THE GOP LAME
DUCK WISH LIST.
THIS IS WHAT THEY HOPE TO
ACCOMPLISH.
THEY WANT TO GET A 10% TAX CUT.
THEY WANT BUILDING THE BORDER
WALL.
STOPPING BIRTH RIGHT
CITIZENSHIP.
CUTTING OFF AID TO CENTRAL
AMERICAN NATIONS AND PROTECTING
PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS.
WILL ANY OF THAT GET
ACCOMPLISHED?
DAVID?
>> WELL, I THINK MAYBE ONE OR
TWO OF THEM WILL.
SEEMS THAT PEOPLE FIND THEIR
POLITICAL ENERGY IN THE LAST
DAYS WHEN THEY SUDDENLY -- AFTER
THEIR CONSTITUENTS SAY THEY
DON'T WANT THEM THERE.
>> Raymond: 15 LEGISLATIVE DAYS,
12 IN THE HOUSE.
THAT'S NOT AN ETERNITY.
>> IT'S AMAZING THAT THERE SEEMS
TO BE THREE MONTHS WHERE NOBODY
COULD FIND ANYTHING TO DO EXCEPT
CAMPAIGN AND NOW IN THE LAST 15
DAYS THERE'S A LIST OF
PRIORITIES.
>> Raymond: WE'LL GET IT DONE.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE A LOT TO GET
TO, AUDRIA.
HERE'S WHAT THEY'RE PLANNING.
THEY HAVE PUT FORWARD THEIR OWN
WISH LIST.
IT INCLUDES LOOKING AT THE
PRESIDENT'S TAX RETURNS, HIS
FAMILY BUSINESS, TRUMP'S DEALING
WITH RUSSIA.
THE STORMY DANIELS PAYMENT AND
THE JAMES COMEY FIRING AND
THERE'S MORE THINGS COMING ABOUT
IVANKA'S PHONE CALLS.
THIS COULD GO ANOTHER TEN
MINUTES.
YOUR THOUGHTS HERE.
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT GRIDLOCK?
>> YEAH.
I DON'T THINK IS BENEFICIAL FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY EITHER.
LET'S TAKE ABOUT ISSUES THAT
AMERICANS CARE ABOUT.
LET'S HAVE A REAL DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE ISSUES AND PRINCIPLES
AND SEE WHERE WE FALL ON THEM.
LET'S HAVE DEALS NEGOTIATED IN
CONGRESS ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
STOP GOING AFTER TRUMP.
PUT OUT YOUR SOLUTIONS AND YOUR
POLICY IDEAS.
>> Raymond: I'M GOING TO TURN TO
2020.
THE DEMOCRATIC CONTENDERS ARE
BEGINNING TO EMERGE.
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
IS AT THE TOP OF THE LIST.
33% OF DEMOCRATS LIKE HIM
ACCORDING TO THAT LAST CNN POLL.
THERE YOU CAN SEE THE HUGE
FIELD.
THIS LOOKS LIKE THE BRADY BUNCH
ON VIAGRA.
THEY'RE JUST EXPLODED.
YOUR THOUGHTS, WHO WILL TAKE THE
LEAD HERE, DAVID?
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE A VERY
TOUGH RACE.
IF I HAVE TO LOOK AT ANYONE, I
SAW A PICTURE OF THE ROCK.
SO I THINK OF THE ROCK RUNS,
HE'S PROBABLY GOT THE BEST SHOT,
THIS IS -- DEMOCRATS DO WELL TO
CONSOLIDATE EARLY AND NOT LET
THIS BE A REPEAT OF 2016 WHERE
THEY END UP IN A SITUATION WITH
ONE PERSON THAT WILL BE THE
LOUDEST LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS --
>> Raymond: PEOPLE HEARD HIM.
>> AND DOMINATE EVERYBODY
ELSE --
>> Raymond: 46% OF VOTERS THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL WIN AGAIN.
47% DON'T IN THE LAST CNN POLL.
THOSE ARE GOOD NUMBERS.
WHO WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE THE
DEMS RUN AGAINST TRUMP?
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
KEEP AN EYE ON SENATOR CORY
BOOKER AND SENATOR HARRIS OR
O'ROURKE OUT OF TEXAS.
THIS ELECTION WILL COME DOWN TO
VALUES.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP PROVED THAT.
PEOPLE VOTED FOR TRUMP, NOT FOR
HIS PERSONALITY BUT FOR THE
VALUES.
PEOPLE ARE DIVIDED.
>> Raymond: IT WILL BE ABOUT
COMPETENCY AND SAFETY AND HOW
THIS ECONOMY ENDS UP.
BEFORE WE GO, I HAVE TO GET YOUR
REACTIONS TO THIS.
LIBERAL FILM MAKER MICHAEL MORE
THAT CALLED ON PEOPLE TO PUT
THEIR BODIES ON THE LINE TO STOP
THE PRESIDENT IS NOW CALLING FOR
THE SHUNNING OF TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
WATCH THIS.
>> YOU CAN'T BUILD A BRIDGE TO A
RACIST OR MISOGYNIST.
THEY HAVE TO BE SHUNNED AND
TREATED LIKE WE TREATED SMOKERS
20 YEARS AGO, TEN YEARS AGO.
RACISTS AND MISOGYNISTS SHUNNED.
>> Raymond: SO ALL TRUMP
SUPPORTERS SHOULD BE SHUNNED.
YOUR REACTION?
>> NAME CALLING DOESN'T HELP.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
WHERE BOTH SIDES COME TOGETHER.
MAYBE DISAGREE BUT DO IT
RESPECTFULLY AND CIVILITY.
THAT KIND OF RHETORIC IS
DIVISIVE AND DANGEROUS.
>> Raymond: IT'S SILLY, DAVID.
REMIND ME THE ATTACKS ON A
CHARLIE BROWN CHRISTMAS THAT
CRITICS ARE SAYING YOU'RE
RACIST, CHARLIE BROWN.
THERE'S FRANKLIN AT THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE TABLE, THIS IS
REALLY -- ISN'T THIS TOO FAR?
THE USE OF RACE TO DEMONIZE
PEOPLE.
A WHOLE SWATH OF AMERICANS?
>> YES.
WE'VE GONE TO FAR.
IT'S THIS TIME OF YEAR WHERE
EVERYBODY IS COMING TOGETHER.